[Musique]
c'est toi qui nous a fait entrer
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
tu vas devoir nous laisser ici c'est pas
logique tout ça j'ai fermé le portail
[Musique]
et s'il n'était jamais parti
et si on l'avait enfermé ici avec nous
sur un script et à quelqu'un
[Musique]
un nouvel hôte
j'ai construit quelque chose
quoi qu'il se passe
on doit l'arrêter
on sent même
le moment venu
oui nous allons tous d'anéantir nous
anéantir ont aussi des amis
et après on s'occupera d'anéantir dans
les monts
enfants sont en danger
qu'on en finisse avec ça
je te battre
mieux que nous tous
mais je veux que tu as qu à l'abri
est ce que c'est que ça
mais four tuent presque briançon
la chose
[Musique]
cameroun je ratais
cols rouges
[Musique]